ازمه السودان تتواصل في ظل عجز الاصوات
الداعيه الى التهدئه عن اقناع الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع بوقف اطلاق النار لكن
السيناريو الحالي للمعارك كان سيبدو
مختلفا لو ان قائد الجيش السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان لم ينجوا من عمليه اقتحام
مقر اقامته عند بدايه هذه المواجهات وكاله
كشفت النقابه عن تفاصيل لم تعرض من قبل
حول عمليه الاقتحام هذه والتي نفذها
مقاتلون قوات الدعم السريع خلال الساعات
الاولى من اندلاع الصراع رؤيه تقول بان
اقتحام مقر اقامه البرهان حدث بالفعل وذلك
نقلا عن عشرات مصادر من طرفي الصراع
والجزئيه الاكثر اثاره في محاوله الاقتحام
هذه هي تصدي البرهان بنفسه للمقاتلين
التابعين للدعم السريع تقول وكاله رويترز
فنقلا عن احد حراس البرهان الشخصيين فان
قائد الجيش حمل بندقيه كلاشنكوف وفتح
النار بنفسه قبل ان ينقله رجال الامن الى
مكان امن وقال الحارس الذي طلب عدم نشر
اسمه ان مقاتلي قوات الدعم السريع قتلوا
اكثر من ثلاثين من حراس البرهان في هذه
المعركه التي تلت الاقتحام قبل ان ينسحبوا
وكانت قوات الدعم السريه قد نشرت مقاطع
فيديو خلال اليوم الثاني للمعارك تقول
انها من داخل مقر اقامه البرهان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات